you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar on the right track
building the neural circuitry for
feeding and smuggling presented by dr.
Zara Matahari postdoctoral scientists
George Washington University I'm
Christie jewel of lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Leica Microsystems to learn more
about our sponsor please visit like our
Microsystems comm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the left side of
your screen this presentation is
educational and this offer is continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
prevent today's speaker dr. Zara
Matahari for a complete biography on dr.
Amano vari please see the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Mona Hari
you may now begin your presentation
thank you thank you for the introduction
and thank you
lifestyle for inviting me to speak and
talk about my project I'm very excited
my name is Zara and today I'm going to
talk about on the project I've been
working on for what around two years and
that would be focused on the normal
secretory for feeding and swallowing
but let me start off by briefly
explaining why it's important in human
there is a genetic disorder called
twenty-two to eleven deletion syndrome
which is caused by a max resolution on
the proximal portion of the lung or two
arm of chromosome 22 22 to 11 deletion
syndrome is very common it occurs in
approximately one in 4,000 lighter and
deleted individuals show complex and
valuable psychiatric phenotypes such as
schizophrenia ADHD autism learning
disabilities as well as a physical
phenotype the physical symptoms are very
proud and include developmental delay
congenital heart defects craniofacial
anomalies hearing loss muscular skeletal
anomalies absent or small sinus and
terrify or gland compromised immune
system and this Asia so what here is
this Vasia this feature is a sitting and
rolling difficulties it occurs in 35 to
80 percent of children with no
developmental disorders it results in
poor nutritional status and increase the
risk of nasal middle ear and respiratory
infections and unfortunately the causes
are unknown
if you look at this feeding and
swallowing
process itself its relies on rapid
coordination of the upgrade I can use
the bow here so it relies on rapid
coordination of the Muslims and
structure in the mouth sword and
esophagus the distal Rattus is control
for your neural circuitry composed of
motor neurons from the hind brain and
prefer all cranial sensory neurons the
motor command includes the maxillary and
the mandibular branch of trigeminal
nerve or cranial nerve 5 for draw
closing the facial nerve seven for job
openings and movement of facial muscles
cranial nerve cranial nerve nine and ten
for pharyngeal and laryngeal muscles and
cranial nerve 12 or hyper ghor so for
pump muscles
and if you look at the mouse you can see
that structure and pattern all these
cranial nerves or very conserved which
is great because now we can use a mouse
as a model system to which study this
Asia but for today I'm going to just
talk about with the chrony on their five
and why cranial nerve five why is
important let me start off by just
explaining it go a little bit in details
about cranial nerve five
Klingon decides responsible for
sanitation in the face and the motor
functions such as biting and chewing it
has three major branches of sonic
maxillary and mandibular branch the
ophthalmic and maxillary nerves are
purely sensory whereas the manipular
branch supplies motor as well as sensory
functions the sensory functions of
cranial nerve 5 is to provide tactile
proprioceptive and receptive to the face
and mouth so just a little bit more
details proprioceptive is a sense of
relative position for example the
position of the food in the mouth is
sensed by these receptors and not
receptive I can be divided into three
categories clinical sensation such as
chili powder in the mouth mechanical
sensation like cutting and crushing and
of course thermal sensation for the
sensation of the heat in the mouth and
the motor command control the movements
of eight muscles including the four
muscles of mastication and together
these sensory and motor neurons
coordinate the movement of the muscles
and structure in order pharyngeal
apparatus and of course with the help of
other cranial nerves
so we had a mouse model for 22 to 11th
edition of syndrome which is called our
cell the first thing we did we examine
whether or not largely pop can exhibit
the Miller defining feature of this Asia
and so we found that like humans modular
pops fail to gain weight they also have
milk aspiration into the narrow
respiratory passages we also saw some of
the exceptions so what I'm showing here
is an example of milk aspiration in PvP
for larger pot fluorescent dye added to
milk just for the illustration purpose
and so you can see that in Wi-Fi pop
when
milk if swallow is nothing left in the
mouth and the esophagus however enlarged
they'll pop milk present in the mouth
and esophagus and also is present in
nasal cavity which is one of the
symptoms of this pager so this result
shows actually confirm our suspicion
that this mouse model can be used as a
mouse model for studying this pager so
that was great and then we look at the
development of cranial nerve 5 in this
now
so what we found was that enlarge the
animals the also the development of
granular 5 is disrupted as early as
endodontic tip 10 5 embryonic day 10 5
so this is a larger image you can see
that the nerves are sparse and this
branch also the complexity and length of
both maxillary and mandibular branches
are significantly diminished in other
words the deeps and VDC and abnormal
growths motor genesis in mutant animals
although these findings are very
informative but they don't show whether
or not the neural circuits that
innervate the auto financial structures
are also disrupted
in fact the development of neural
circuitry depends on three major
processes
selphie the specification in ox
formation and axonal guidance our lab
has been focused on 12 these processes
delegated specification and axonal
guidance and we have a strong evidence
that in mutant animals the balance
between cell proliferation and
differentiation is significantly
disrupted but I'm not going to talk
about that it's dirty today I will just
focus on axon path one thing
in order to investigate axonal growth
you needed to study them in their native
3d structure which was not accessible by
conventional serial sections so what we
did the label axons with a normal tracer
and then utilize confocal microscope to
look at external trajectories and
morphology we used by sighting as our
neural tracer here is an example of xi v
and radio indicated by sliding um
roughly around 20 to 40 nanometer by
your sliding is injected in the branch o
or 1b which makes the lower jaw with a
glass metal type it under microscopic
observation after the injection and
their use very transfer to subculture
media and incubated for roughly about
another and a half at 37 then they six
clear and process for 2d imaging
here I'm going to show you a video of
the right type and Mario interpreted by
your siding at pax5
one of the quadratures bio siding is
that it can channel in both directions
and enter grade and retrograde so after
the injection by reciting travels
through the axons Wipro greatly and they
will still body of the sensory neurons
in detroit geminal and motor neurons in
the high brain you can see that the
axons are labeled very nicely and you
can actually track them on to the
injection site this is a tie image of
the embryo is about 350 400 microns deep
and the image again is the injection
size trigeminal and the hindbrain and
it's about it takes about 17 18 hours to
to be completed and you can see that
this young one is it I'm not sure if you
can actually notice but they located in
different plane for example the sensory
neurons are located more to the surface
and the motor neurons they are located
deeper in the tissue so
I'm sorry okay so here what I'm showing
is a snapshot of again the trigeminal
and the hind brain and again I want to
just to emphasize that the sensory
neurons the same quality of the sensory
neurons are located in the trigeminal
ganglion and the motor neurons are
located in the hind brain another thing
is that the essentially axons are going
to the hind brain and vital case being
very nicely in the hind brain and going
directly towards our target here is
again another example of interested in
video and you can see that on the axons
later very nicely from the injection
site and the dye goes to the cell body
of sensory neurons and you can actually
see the axons going to the hind brain so
by now we develop the technique and just
be ready to look at the actual growth
and pass funding
so the first thing that the app was
whether or not axons going to the
correct target so to answer that
question we injected sensory neurons in
the trigeminal ganglion on read by
siding conjugated to Alex on floor 594
and 488 and observe the axonal
trajectories into the branchial arch 1 a
which makes the upper jaw and arch B
which makes the loyal job this is an
example of the right type M video
projected and you can see that the
simple neurons in the anterior partner
enter your portion of the triangle and
general going directly to the arch 1a
and the one located in the posterior
portion going to break your arch won't
be other words they are very aligned and
the repeat experimental eyes and
compared on 21 type and largely mutant
and in fact we didn't see any
significant difference between larval
and white time other thing other words
even in mutant animal of the axon the
axons could find the target and go to
the target directly so there was a
difference here then we look at the axon
mythology so to do that after taking 3d
images are use the software to track the
axons and to be precise I actually been
through each three site once a plane by
plane and manually trace axons and then
use the software to connect the dots and
give me a cheesy image this is an image
of the track axon there are four key
points here that we have to convey
attention to first you can see that the
cell bodies of the sensory neuron
located in China general ganglia and
motor neurons are the hindbrain they
both are going to the correct branchial
arch sensory axons bifurcates into hind
brain very nicely and also motor axons
coming out of the cell body and going
directly to the target so we repeat
experiments are in mutant enlarger and
video and we did see that light white
type the cell bodies are located in the
correct position and both of them
actually both sensory and motor neurons
going to the corrector large but we did
see for a normal phenotype one of which
is we call it looking we have here is
samples of looking this is a larger
image of these purple neurons here you
can see loping we have an open here in
the hind brain which is this is a larger
image this is what I call data looping
because it's just like two loops
together and here is another example of
that are looking in the hybrid I should
mention that the looping is not a
specific to the hindbrain video single
pins in the hind brain as well as in the
prestress the success phenotype is what
it's called what we called it sprouting
so if you remember on Wi-Fi axons going
to the high brain and by side case very
nicely and going to the target but what
we see here is like the king that the
axons are in the navigation mode which
they try to sense the environment which
is abnormal in this location so we we
call this morphology sprouting the third
morphology was what we call this routing
you can see that it seems that the motor
electrons here it's kind of lost going
to the wrong direction and somehow
corrected itself and then coming back up
and go into this on twice direction
and the fourth one was branching so
sometimes close to the end of the axons
for sometimes even in the middle of a
cloud I saw that the axons branch or
make a fourth and then from one cell
body there was two axons coming here
going to the target which was abnormal
this is a summary table of the results
out of 13 white card interview and to
see the axons I said that if we are one
of them going to the creek on branchial
arch I did see for the 6% looping in
wild-type and also I did see our
abnormal phenotypes with the low
frequency 1.7% branch changes by
percentage Valley and zero percentage
crowding in the mutant animal out of 15
n vu and 70 axon analyzed again they are
going to the correct branchial arch 55%
of them lake looking but if you look at
the other phenotype the frequency the
frequency of others in your child was
much higher in daughter Annie mode 11%
branching compared to one person 17% is
rallying compared to 5% and wanting all
person as crowded if you put everything
in a table together just a comfort you
can see that since that there is no
difference of a looping they are kind of
they're similar but you can see that the
frequency of abnormal phenotype is
significantly higher in most animals
compared to give in wild-type and this
is purchasing much significant but
um so even though these new things I was
thinking about it quite some time I kind
of bothered me in terms of Y V to see
the same frequency and I realized that I
should mention that this way that I've a
score 15 at right here when I saw one
loop i discord it at a little bit you
know time but then I realize that there
are more looping in Rochdale so then I
counted each note and then this is a
summary of the results then
interestingly so um the y axis shows the
percent of the axons and it shows the
number of loops you can see that in
white I'd more than 60 percent of the
cases um they have just shown one loop
in around 20 percent to two loops and
very few showing cribbage however in
Northville it was the opposite way so
around 20 percent trying to undo and
then most of them like 30 percent two
loops and we also saw three loops and
even more actuators sometimes I did see
ten loops in one axon and that
difference was significant we do see
more looking in Newton axons and also um
I I looked at the number of being
attached to a spa so and the result is
on the right here the y axis shows the
number of connections and it shows of
each condition and each dot should
represent one axon so you can see that
are 30 of axons Voisin axons they don't
show any phenotype I do see one
phenotype which was mostly looking in 23
axons and only three whites are axons
show to phenotype
there as in Rochdale 25 show the
phenotype 52 had one singer type eleven
axon I'm show two thing apply which was
significant
more than three in bright light and also
I have two axons that show a phenotype
again the difference was very
significant
so just to summarize this part we found
that a wild-type and volatile animal
both sensory and motor neuron directly
project to equip Michael or larger
cranial nerve axons however exhibits
abnormal phenotypes such as looping
branching and sprouting and sprouting so
these phenotypes are rarely documented
in vivo in the beta t hat and so our
normal approach allows us to observe
this phenotype with cellular precision
so then the next question that we asked
was what is the mechanism for this
disruption and this abnormal morphology
if you look at the hindbrain developed
and one of the signaling molecules that
establishes the anterior posterior
clarity is retina captive here is in
situ hybridization of t95 hindbrain with
626 b1 probe which is originated
athletes regulator catabolic enzyme you
can see that in one size with like
access is mostly expressed in the
rhombomere five and six
you lost remember you however regional
acid expression is expanded towards
enter your ramen ears but just think
that the identity of the cells the
interior portion of portion of the
hindbrain
is been disrupted this is very very
important because the early patterning
of the hind brain is crucial for not
only motor neuron a specification but
also no press drive pre-processing along
as the last branchial arch
differentiation if you remember I said
add the self ADA specification and
external growth which is guided by the
environmental cue which in the
case is invite environmental cues in the
home in the branchial arches are very
very important for establishing the role
of circuitry interestingly by
genetically lowering the exploration of
rhythmic asset in the hi brain we were
able to restore y-type cranial nerve you
know type in larger lines in other words
while restoring the identity of the
cells in the anterior hind brain we
rescued external growth and cranial
nerve phenotype or should say cranial
nerve 5 phenotype now the question is
whether or not we can rescue the
abnormal axon morphology at cellular
level so to answer that question again I
injected by siding into the branchial
arch 1 B let it sit for another I have
and then fix clear and process the
embryo for through the energy and this
is a summary of the result in rescue
animals out of innocence and videos and
66 and a live action again everybody
going to the correct branchial arch IDC
53% looking which was very close to
white wine but I did see abnormal
phenotype which left frequency in rescue
animal IDC three-person branch in
compared to 11% in life in outside in
large though 4.5% stranding compared to
17% in mutant animal and little person
is from being compared to one point
score person again if you want to
summarize you can see clearly here that
the frequency of the abnormal phenotype
is very similar to do in wild-type and
in fact there was no significant
difference between wild-type and rescue
animals
and again if you look at the number of
phenotype their axons again y-axis shows
the number of phenotype and we have each
condition here you can see that the risk
you are very similar to wild-type we are
we have 30 axons with no phenotype 32
axis with only one phenotype and for
excellence with two phenotypes which was
very close to three exons in one time so
the conclusion is that yes by rescuing
or the identity of the sudden the hungry
we were able to not only restore their
cranial nerve phenotype and growth but
also we were able to rescue the action
or mythology in in these animals and
just to summarize if you show that in
wash-down the anterior-posterior
patterning of the hind brain is altered
also in using the cranial nerve 5 action
of group and pat bonding are disrupted
we found that cranial nerve fiber type
in newtrich animals can be rescued by
genetically reducing the level of
rhetoric acid in the hind brain
and finally the 3d imaging help us to
resolve compromised action pad on bacon
mutant animals that might otherwise have
been missed using conventional
techniques
and with that I would like to thank
people who helped me in in this project
I would like to thank my advisers at the
la Monte dr. moody dr. poverty loss the
director of nano fabrication and
emerging center and dr. mania for
technical support and of course
everybody in the lab I would like to
thank the Department of anatomy and cell
biology the department of pharmacology
and physiology and also the nano
fabrication and imaging center and of
course the monthly resources and thank
you very much
you
thank you dr. Mata Hari for your
informative presentation we will now
start a live Q&A portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now just click on the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started our first question is dr.
Mata Hari
what is the specimen thickness limit for
imaging in 3d with sufficient resolution
to do single axon process tracing well
it really depends on the objectives that
you're using and of course the metal
doctor clearing in my case I used be a
BB benzyl alcohol benzyl benzoate and I
use oil immersion 20x and by using that
specific objective I have like the
maximum of 450 much on working distance
but again if you're using clarity and
then use the water immersion objective
you have much more working distance for
example 3 4 millimeter again it depends
on your objective
our next question how much depth can you
measure from imaging
um how much dips in terms of
again it depends on your it depends on
your objectives if you using oil I mean
water email imagine objective you can
cover up to five six two millimeter
now are there any alternate oh excuse me
are there any alternate clearing methods
other than ba BB I mean of course there
are a list of other reagents that we can
use and it really depends on what your
question is what tissue you try to clear
and so based on that you can use
different method or optimize based your
own condition for example one of the
early tissue clearing method was ba BB
and disco which is based on organic
solvent but then there are other bunch
of chemicals and came along which are
more like a hydrophilic chemical urea
for example if I want to give you a
couple of examples Gill GDB clear and
another one that actually people are
start using it very much is clarity
which uses embedding the tissue into
hydrogel polymer and then you can use
oil
I'm sorry water immersion objective they
are a bunch of them and this is just
some of them that I mentioned
have you tried whole mount antibody
labeling combined with bio site and
tracing
that's a good question not really we
thought about it it's very cool if for
example if you want to look at for
example when you're near five and you
see which one going to the branchial
arch you can do for example 2j1 and what
you're staining a combined what by your
siding but we didn't do it that's that's
a good way of doing things but that was
not our concern and no we didn't try
that okay our next question in one of
the imaging you used to dice and it
appears as some of the neurons are
double labeled is it because of the
properties of bio seitan that can cross
through gap junctions or because these
neurons send branches to both locate
well actually that's a very very good
question and to be honest be do you have
some idea but we are not sure one of
them I mean I don't know maybe drawback
by citing it leaks so even though your
inject to the anterior portion it leaks
a little bit going through through the
cell body in the posterior portion data
labeling could be the making of the by
citing and this is what I'm willing to
accept but in rather than getting like
branches into branchial arch we didn't
see that much evidence to support that
that they getting to label axon because
it was just cell body data labels not be
the actions I would guess that it was
just some licking I'm going to the cell
body at the injection site
our next question could sparse
recombination Brainbow approaches be
used with this technique to resolve
multiple axons processes cells in one
single animal and increase overall ends
for measurement well I mean let me
explain by with what Brainbow is for the
people who don't know Brainbow is a
process by which individual neurons in
the brain can be distinguished from
neighboring neurons and then it has been
developed in Harvard University and the
way that it's been done they're using
clean locks recombination in order to
put a specific fluorescent under
specific promoter then different cell
type Express different dye which is very
nice in terms of increasing the number
of n I assume n meaning the number of
axons
I don't think so because the number of
axons is just the one that is labeled
with bio siding but the cool thing is we
combine Brainbow with bio siding
then we can actually distinguish for
example if in your specific motor
neurons in the hind brain is more
disruptive than the others and this
phenotype because by the way that I've
done I have no idea which type of motor
neurons in the hindbrain disrupted is it
all of them is it some of them and that
method the combination of Brainbow with
by siding could actually answer that
part of the question that if any
specific motor neurons are being
disrupted or more affected by this
deletion that's a good question
- dr. Mata Hari let's just um
[Music]
let's see okay it looks like we have
time for one more and let's go with this
one
do you think the looping phenomenon is a
normal process that is unregulated in
the deletion model it could be the will
to be honest we are not sure we don't
know if looping has any like function in
arm in in like external morphology or
what it do anything so first of all we
don't know that part but I found the
literature in the in the brain that
author suggests that the looping could
be a sign of degeneration in the neurons
in the hindbrain
we were not sure if this is the thing
thing that you are seeing here but it
could be and we don't know I mean this
is just kind of a speculation and in
terms of what it does in white side
axons we don't know I don't know if it
has a specific function to be honest in
wild side actions
thank you dr. mana very um do you have
any final comments for our audience
um the final comment is I think the
method that you're used could actually
help us to answer the most basic
questions again if you wanted to section
through the axons or section to the to
the hindbrain you probably could not get
the good idea of the morphology and
what's going on in the axonal type one
being just using a confocal microscopy
you just give us the power to solve this
problem at the cellular resolution which
was actually very cool
you
thank you dr. Mata Hari um thank you so
much for your time today and your
important research thank you for having
me absolutely and we would also like to
thank lab roots and specifically are
sponsored by crest Microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go I would like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through April
2019 laborat swill alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events thanks for joining
us until next time goodbye very classy
Thanks
you